[Music]  welcome to the largest fiber summit in  the world this is not just a conference  we have a mission  our vision is that fiber based  connectivity will transform and enhance  the way we live do business and interact  connecting everyone everything  everywhere  our ambition ubiquitous fiber  connectivity why I hear you ask  enhancing the quality of life  innovation machine learning and  analytics for new insights fueling the  economy and the industry increasing  human interaction we are here to connect  the dots we connect the worlds of  Technology Policy and finance  we are the pioneers we believe in the  revolutionary future I cannot think of  anything that can replace fiber optics  in the next 1,000 years I can't think of  a better system you  me me  and me  on a mission together we build the fiber  future together light up the dark  welcome to the ftth conference 2018  [Music]